So, let's recap. Remember originally, the tone is a neutral stimulus. It does
not elicit any response except perhaps the dog orienting, meaning it heard it.
Then, we pair our tone with the unconditioned stimulus. Recall that a
unconditioned stimulus automatically causes a reflexive response. In this case,
the meat powder automatically causes the dog to salivate. Next, after these
repeated pairings, tone, food, tone, food, we test to see if classical
conditioning has occurred. To do this we present the conditioned stimulus alone
and we see does the animal respond. In this case, the animal did salivate so
now we can call the tone a conditioned stimulus and the salivation to the tone
a conditioned response.